vous m'avez manqué moi ça fait bizarre
ça fait longtemps qu'on savait presque
un mois que j'ai pataugé dans son studio
mon gars je suis content d'être auto mer
démontée t'oublier je sais plus du tout
ce qu'ils pensent de moi comment je vais
faire moi abord avoir confiance en moi
sans savoir ce que j'en pense après un
mois sans vidéo un mois sans tourner un
mois loin de youtube
les gens m'ont peut-être oublié je ne
sais plus ce que vous pensez de moi je
ne sais plus où nous en sommes dans
notre relation mais j'ai trouvé un moyen
de faire le poids connaissez vous le
site sens critique le site propose de
découvrir de noter de commenter des
oeuvres culturelles dans plusieurs
domaines fils cyril télévisée livres
bandes dessinées albums et morceaux
musicaux jeux vidéo et youtube
oui oui mes vidéos sont donc des oeuvres
culturelles des amis à quelques années
j'ai découvert ce site et y avait pas
mal de critiques à l'encontre de youtube
heures et les critiques à mon encontre
et est surtout négative alors on va les
lire pour faire le point sur notre
relation savoir où nous en sommes
finalement c'est un petit peu comme si
on allait voir un psy pour coupe sofcap
hadopi alors intervenants lutter en
charge cousy avec une photo de 2013
merci rima j'adore je suis acteur et
auteur merci pour ce fait du bien à mon
ego mais je suis pas du tout né le 20
janvier 96
pourtant c'était pas compliqué à trouver
en tapant son nom sur google on le
trouve tout de suite c'est parti pour
les critiques il y à 37 critiquer je
crois que il ya eu des critiques depuis
2013 2014 donc ce sera pas ça parlera
pas des mêmes choses en fonction de la
période
quoi qu'il en soit c'est des gens qui
ont pris du temps pour écrire quelque
chose à mon égard et rennes pour ça je
suis touché même si négatif il ya une
démarche de bienveillance qui est
certaine à mon avis alors la première
c'est le nerf en fait je consulte plus
n'a pas vraiment sa place sur sens
critique puisque le site est avant tout
un site culturel
[Musique]
la première phrase elle même est
tellement cher groupe alors bon c'est
vrai que squeeze n'est pas un artiste
ces vidéos sont spontanés improvisé seul
le montage et travailler clément viens
t'asseoir je te laisse aller si tu peux
garder les revenus de la chaîne avec
mais son but n'est pas de faire de la
route nous apprendre quelque chose son
but est de nous faire rire de nous faire
découvrir des jeux et en ce qui me
concerne ça marche
ces vidéos font rire et ce n'est pas
parce que je suis sûr sens critique je
ne peux plus rire les blacks
complètement débile ou bien bof
oui vas-y mais un continues comme ça tu
es sur la bonne voie ce n'est pas non
plus parce que j'aime les vidéos de
squeeze que je suis une préado débiles
qui a des mauvais goût et aucune culture
tu as raison dé la teigne culture de
domme t même des personnes qu'on a le
plus de france je sais que je me tienne
un peu de sujets mais qu'un de squeeze
me rappelle celui des comédies
françaises bien débile
tu as atteint paye toujours un truc
début je veux pas te rappeler un truc
sympa quoi assentiment bien ça te
rappelles-tu un truc débile c'est triste
quoi j'ai l'impression qu'on rigole tous
plus ou moins honteusement mais on n'ose
pas donné une bonne note parce que sur
sens critique ça ne rend pas bien
du coup parfois j'en viens presque à me
demander si la majorité des sources
critiqueurs n'est pas un peu hypocrite
ou n'a pas le sens de l'humour je peux
tout à fait comprendre qu'on aime parce
que des vidéos et de attentant sa part
en débat politique sur le public de sens
critique là je je je moi je veux me mêle
pas à ça je connais pas je sais pas
jamais on trouvait normal car fans de
truffaut 10 regarde moi c'est imbécile
de fans de godard encore que je n'ai pas
choisi le meilleur exemple parce que
ceux qui aiment godard dont je fais un
peu partie ne sont jamais très bien vu
ouais grave grave j'ai compris l'arrêt
fait tout du ouf quand j'ai la vidéo de
cuisine à un moment de détente j'ai
l'impression d'être avec un ami facile à
l'air sympa sincère il nous parle nous
fait rire il a l'air de s'amuser lui
aussi facile et milles derrière tout le
monde ne pouvait pas faire ce qu'il fait
il a une présence
il sait faire avantage dynamique non ça
c'est toi clément
il a réussi à condenser plusieurs heures
de vidéo en dix minutes n'en sais rien
de compliqué c'est pourquoi je me dis
qu'il ya quand même bien en matière à
noter
vidéo de squeeze alors fais ton bêtes à
plumes et 10 mois la note que je mérite
nerfs après juste pour le fun mois les
critiques ça m'atteint pas je m'en fous
de la note 1 mais bien par exemple j'ai
pas envoyer un message à hakkari tout
pour vous dire que je suis noté sept sur
dix sans aucun sens né à sa critique
elle est géniale parce qu'il m'a mis des
grosses balles quand même dans la tête
tu aimes un peu planté son couteau comme
ça et après qu'est ce qu'il a fait mais
qu'il a mis la pommade le petit
pansement sur la pommade s'arrête pas là
il m'a fait un petit bisou sur le front
voilà ce qu'il a fait n'est à j'espère
tout va bien alors nouvelles critiques
publiées par yuri coup le 17 février
2016 je mets une note plus généreuse que
la majorité des gens ici car au moins un
squeeze nous permet de découvrir des
jeux sortis de nulle part et dont on
parle à tort très peu du coup je regarde
de temps en temps les premières minutes
de ces vidéos en coupant le son est
histoire de découvrir le jeu et puis
finit tôt adacore a beaucoup tu t'es
trompé faut aller sur gamekult ou
jeuxvideo.com mois un autre truc en fait
et comme ça tu auras le son du jeu en
plus le pot vie crois qu'il ya que moi
qui parle de jeux ou rich ou le 28
décembre 2014 qui nous dit j'ai chopé le
cancer de la constipation huawei que
j'espère que tu vas mieux de sa fierté
d'énièmes youtuber gaming cancéreux qui
jouent à des jeux d'horreur
inintéressant il est quotidiennement mis
en valeur par youtube ainsi que par une
forte d'ado attardé de 10 16 ans il nage
aussi du sel y a qu'à voir le public dû
siffler un game show pour en avoir un
petit aperçu
mais je veux pas de quoi tu parles déjà
été soyez un peu objectif ils ont tous
au moins 17 ans il cumule les millions
de vues en masse forcément quand on fait
des vidéos commentées sur des faux jeu
d'horreur et sur des jeux what the fuck
ça fait tourner la machine à fric
on attend mais là il ya une tempête au
salon consacré aux voyages de troll mais
je le comprends un peu raide tout c'est
qu'à l'époque les salaires des youtube
des gros youtuber commencé à s'y
reconnaître ce qu'on fait souvent
l'amalgamé on croit souvent que c'est
tout et youtube heures il ya énormément
d'argent alors que pas du tout on est
une poignée a très bien gagner notre vie
c'est vrai mais y'en a plein à côté
qu'il ya beaucoup moins et on a encore
plus qui galèrent en vivres du coup
c'est assez nouveau à l'époque
d'apprendre que des mecs qui se filment
en jouant aux jeux vidéo gagne des
sommes assez élevé et vous ça a créé
beaucoup de de jalousie et des
frustrations et c'est totalement
compréhensible car je peux pas lui en
vouloir et où le mec surjoue à mort que
ce soit dans l'écrit ou les mimiques
poussent des cris qui font bien mal aux
tympans et où j'espère que t'as pas fini
sourds malentendants à cause de moi
auquel cas je comprendrais la violence
de tactique je m'excuse n'oublions pas
le suffrage de la queue de cyprien
pour encore ramener du monde chez lui et
l'ouverture d'une chaîne avec ce dernier
qui n'est rien d'autre qu'un ramassis de
pub à peine déguisée qui n'arrange pas
les choses
et vous avez une belle petite [ __ ] a
bonne entendeur a bonne entendeur
redfoo je ne peux pas t'en vouloir tuer
le bienvenu dans le studio c'est un jour
tu passes par l'un de ses quatre
n'hésite pas en tout cas jean battault
numéro à mâcon qui l'hiver prochain
quand il y aura rendu libre et tout te
demanderas d'écrire quelques critiques
pour dégivrer les routes 1 grâce à tour
celle ouais je reviens de vacances et
c'est moi mais ouvre d un peu là je sais
que vous avez été habitué aux critiques
de h le 18 septembre 2015 n'ai jamais
aimé squeeze ça commence bien enfin
cette espèce de vieille adolescents
braillard immature qui m'appelle fait
déclencher quelques sourires en
plusieurs vidéos ok ok bah au moins ya
quelques sourires déjà je n'ai jamais
apprécié jusqu'ici ok ben là dessus
c'est vrai j'ai décidé de redonner une
chance à dans des vidéastes et plus
populaires du youtube français attend h
tu veux dire que tu vas peut-être sauvé
ma carrière je vais direct j'ai été
assez surpris par la qualité de
certaines de ces certaines vidéos
je vais dire est que j'ai été assez
surpris par la tournure bizarre de la
tournure bizarre de certaines de ses
phrases dans sa critique celle des
catacombes de paris m'avait beaucoup plu
le gros acheteur de squeeze que j'étais
à l'époque d'authie bien l'admettre ce
garçon a bien changé il a perdu la
moitié de sa crétinerie sac gamineries
sa tv dit ouais bon ça va aussi
alors qu est digne de satan officielle
au [ __ ] de merde dernière fois que
j'ai vu c'était pour signer un pacte me
menant à la réussite de ma carrière sur
youtube bon vous savez quoi je pense
qu'on a tous plus ou moins conscience
que ce que je fais squeeze c'est de la
merde quand même bien écris moi même
ayant demandé à des amis ce qui leur
plaît chez ce tocard il répondait qu'il
savait que c'était débile mais que ces
gros n'importe quoi qu'ils aient marqué
fiore
en fait j'étais vraiment la téléréalité
youtube à l'époque gérard jacquet à
l'époque tout le monde savait que
c'était pas très fut fut un peu exagéré
un peu pourri et tout m'est souvent de
regarder quand même parce que ça faisait
du bien de se vider la tête et pas faire
marcher le cerveau quand on regardait
ses vidéos là et c'est exactement le
même discours que les gens qui regardent
la télé réalité on s'est trop drôle ce
mec n'est pas drôle il est lourd mais il
a au moins le mérite de prendre du recul
sur ce qu'il fait même si ce
gouvernement son public le plus jeune et
puis merde mais aussi il participa
cyprien gaming pas bon ça tu en joues et
randonneurs après notre pack mais
apparemment ça ne marche pas tu me
détestes nova critique écrite pas
soutient le 26 mai 2010 huit ans ces
récentes sur youtube il fait le buzz à
des millions de fans et des millions de
vues à chaque vidéo messieurs sens
critique c'est pas pareil je désolé pour
la voie que je fais mais ça ressemble à
des phrases de voix off de télé et ça
c'est une boîte de thé pour moi bref
pourquoi je mets 8 sur 10 et 1 youtuber
aussi bâché par ce site
parce que tous les goûts youtube et sur
la toile du ko cher fait partie des plus
humains je dirais vous avez vous a
changé
comme il fait un compliment objectif il
a démarré sur des jeux vidéo il a
ensuite poursuivi sur ces défis de
squeeze qui étaient des oeuvres
culturelles hors du commun pour revenir
sur la forme avec ses jeux vidéo avec un
humour certes pas forcément hilarant
mais spontanée ai jamais réfléchi à
l'avance haut ça je te le fais pas dire
ces derniers temps il s'est lancé dans
développe des jeux de société et autres
vidéos détente avec son entourage
commencent à aborder un coût des thèmes
drôle à souhait un autre des thèmes
intrigant et franchement son évolution
se ressent il est absolument adorable 7
merci soutien tu as besoin de soutien
mon numéro
chers amis il est maintenant temps
d'élire la dernière critique larmes de
plomb le 14 septembre 2010 est le duc de
youtube à 100 ça va être du second degré
bien drôle allez on y va après des
débuts hésitants et très brouillon avec
entre autres des gameplay sur des fps et
des tutos très douteux squeeze découvre
que dubaï
il se rend compte finalement qu'il n'est
qu'un piètre joueur et comprend que son
destin celle de l'inter tenait à je vois
pas que tout ça c'est une critique sur
moi je sais on dirait pas ordonner une
thèse vraiment mais c'est sur moi
montage épileptique cris hurlements
podcast cryptic est la limite du no fun
total sensibilité artistique titanesque
avec des leds plaît à plus de 2 millions
de vues par épisode sur the last
guardian hop sp.a 10 millions sur uchi
mauriste avéré avec ces nouveaux
comparses maxence mcphail carlito et
tant d'autres il sortira développe du
futur fera des volants et roger
n'hésitera pas à addis abeba malgré sa
fanbase très actif sur les réseaux est
bien plus squeeze est plus qu'un homme
il a au fur et à mesure construisent
nacre la personnalité avant gardiste et
a toujours su où se placer toujours su
ce qu'il fallait faire pour être au delà
des tendances mettre moins de huit au
duc s'est crashé sur l'art longvic roi
10 sur 10 larmes de plomb je suis
peut-être le duc de youtube mais tu es
le duc de sens critique
c'est magnifique mes amis c'est la fin
de cette vidéo sur sens critique vous
savez quoi c'est une idée de vidéos que
j'avais eue je crois en 2015 mais comme
il y avait que des critiques négatives
et que j'étais un peu plus fragile
psychologiquement j'avais moins
confiance en moi et c'est je me
cherchais un peu bas j'avais pas trop eu
le courage de la faire et j'ai bien fait
je pense que sa mort est animé j'aurais
été un bel os dans mon lit manga pendant
deux semaines j'étais content d'avoir lu
toutes ces critiques avec vous c'est
trop rigolo c'est bien écrit et même
s'il ya pas mal toutes négatives des
fois il ya des gens qui sont quand même
un peu trop salée il ya quand même
beaucoup de gens je trouve très objectif
est qu'ils disent des trucs assez vrai
eh bien merci à venir regarder la vidéo
juste
cette petite vidéo retour vous aura plu
j'avais pas envie de faire une vidéo
secrète pour le retour je voulais faire
une vidéo un peu ours parle on lit des
trucs ensemble voilà c'est plus rigolo
pour ce retour et puis la prochaine fois
je crois qu'il ya une vidéo un peu ce
raid pas vraiment sereine mais un truc
on va pas dormir on va repartir chez
désolé vous fait des gros bisous je vous
dis à bientôt je suis content d'être de
retour j'espère que vous êtes content
aussi d'être de retour au taf au
concours même si j'ai des doutes compter
sur moi pour vous divertir un maximum
jusqu'au prochaines grandes vacances la
bonne chose pour vous j'espère que vous
êtes bien reposé que vous êtes au top
vous attaquer la rentrée avec de
l'énergie avec de l'envié et puis voilà
je souhaite le meilleur et je vous dis à
très vite dans une prochaine vidéo big
bisou go2 dur big bisou qui est très
moyen au revoir attention c'est pas
encore finie je profite de la fin de
cette vidéo pour revenir pour la
première et dernière fois sur le truc
que j'avais fait des buts parce que je
tiens à m'excuser ce qui m'a poussé à
faire ce tweet c'est des vrais
témoignages poignants qui dénonçaient
les actes honteux d'une minorité
youtuber est pas tous attention comme
vous avez pu lire la plupart des noms
des gens à qui je pensais au moment du
tweet sont sortis dans la presse ces
histoires vont maintenant être réglés
devant la vraie justice parce qu'il a ce
qu'il faut comme preuves et pas de voir
celle de twitter mais il ya un projet
complètement merdé c'est pour ça que je
reviens là dessus en donnant aucun nom
pour des raisons légales ça crée un
malentendu général c'est devenu pour
certains une sorte de chasse aux
sorcières un petit jeu très malsain ya
pas mal de personnes qui sont même allés
jusqu'à créer des photomontages de
fausses conversation a créé des mêmes à
faire des blagues de mauvais goût et je
pense qu'on devrait pas trop rire d'un
sujet qui est aussi grave en fait est la
conséquence de tout ça c'est l'immense
diffamation que certains youtuber ont
subi à cause de moi ça entaché leur
image à tort et son prix est gratuite
d'un bon paquet de gens mal intentionnés
qui voulait juste récupérer drt du buzz
en foutant le bordel en fait mais qu'ils
sont fous tu es complètement de la cause
je pense par exemple à norman que je
visais pas du tout et qui s'est
quasiment tous pris gratuitement dans la
gueule alors beaucoup de personnes
pensent que j'ai pas être responsable de
la réaction des gens face à mon tweet
moi je pense que j'ai ma part de
responsabilité là dedans et c'est pour
ça que je reviens sur ce sujet
aujourd'hui je m'excuse auprès de
youtube heures qui ont pris la tempête
de twitter et de ces rageux c'était
vraiment pas mon intention donc j'espère
que ça n'a eu aucun impact sur vous
aucune conséquence maintenant ferme le
sujet le sujet est clos la justice la
vraie justice a tout ce qu'il faut pour
prendre la relève vous en faites pas et
je pense que tout le monde à sa manière
tire sa propre leçon de cette histoire
donc ça serait cool que maintenant
youtube ça redevienne un espace de
créativité de bonnes sont des deux
de bienveillance voilà cette fois c'est
la vraie fin de la vidéo on peut cliquer
sur une autre
[Musique]